let's do it let's do it you heard them
we've got exclusive interviews and
footage from the recording sessions of
the incredible lineup of stars in sing
2. we're talking some serious music and
acting legends how many number one hits
do we got let's dive in just imagine it
a spectacular musical number one it's
hard to pick which scarlett johansson
character is our favorite black widow or
ash the coolest porcupine around i'm ash
wet
the actress has been doing voice over
for years seriously we're talking
decades one of her earliest underwater
princess mindy spongebob wherever you
are you better hurry recording scene 2
was quite a different experience though
since they did it all during a pandemic
we recorded it in such isolation just
because she was often recording alone
didn't mean she wasn't digging the whole
process though especially when it came
to some of the tunes she got to belt out
i don't need the demo it i know the song
number two yes the bono of you two is in
fact the voice of musician clay callaway
in the sing sequel it is always a party
when bono shows up as far as personality
goes he was a pretty perfect pick for
the part some people sing for a living
some people sing to survive i am one of
the latter this was very new territory
for bono never having done an animated
feature film but he knocked it out of
the park even the director garth
jennings could see it he was just
enthusiasm from the start curiosity and
enthusiasm and equal measure i mean you
couldn't ask for more yeah we'd be
pretty jazzed if we were directing bono
too in terms of being a director knowing
that this character is going to be
voiced by bono it's as good as it gets
as for bono himself's favorite part well
let's just say he has excellent taste
and we love it too
number three it wouldn't be sing without
this fabulous singing pig i play rosita
in sing two no wonder reese came back
for such a great role witherspoon is no
stranger to movies or voice over but
performing in sing well it's literally
my dream come true but of course that
didn't come without intimidation i had
to sing prince ariana grande you too
i was so scared it was definitely worth
braving through the nerves since the
actress found one particularly special
song i got to sing an ariana grande song
and it was so fun singing break free it
just felt like there was a song in my
heart and just had to come out and it
was break free and i didn't even know
until i got to sing it it's no wonder
her performance is so good with that
kind of passion behind it made me sound
good number four this might sound crazy
what we're about to say but yes that was
pharrell williams you heard voicing
alfonso in sync too it's such an
incredible cast already and then to add
bono and pharrell it's like dreams come
true yeah no kidding
what's even cooler is the fact that the
singer has never had a major film role
before this was a solid first choice for
sure fingers crossed we get more
pharrell as animated animals soon it's a
testament to the way the audience is
connected with the first movie that
musicians of that caliber want to come
and be a part of it it's super super
exciting and quite surreal number five
couldn't resist coming back for more
sing fun i was falling in love kelly
isn't usually on a set and when she is
in a recording booth she's typically
singing as herself singing is it's
everything but this time her voice gave
life to mina again i completely forgot
that there was a camera on me because
you just get so into the scene and into
the moment recording during the pandemic
meant a lot of time was spent in that
booth alone mr moon i'm not so good in
small space lucky for kelly she got to
start playing around with her part a bit
early i was like you know i have a
studio like i didn't want to like have
to wait super long so i just kind of
offered it i was like i could record
stuff if you guys want oh and the vibes
super chill it was cool just being at
home you know like in my sweats even
when we would go in to record parts in
in their studio it was just like
relaxing the dream cast dream songs
what's not to love i've gotten to sing
all these iconic incredible songs so
i've never once been like huh i don't
know about this one let's maybe try this
step together drop number six usually
his face is on screen but who could
resist the chance to play the buster
moon again buster's the most active
koala that i've that probably there is
on the planet in the universe voice
acting can be a dream for an actor
wanting to play around with their
performance that's one of the great
things you don't even have to think
about what you're wearing so i don't
know what the hell i was wearing there's
nothing self-conscious about it try and
screw up you can't for the sing sequel
the buster moon actor got to stay close
to home to record from my studio in
austin texas wait in his own house yeah
at my office that work from home life
came with an extra special perk the
movie became a family affair okay guys
just like we rehearsed my daughter vida
got a couple lines in this movie
honestly her role might be better than
her dad's she plays a piglet who's scuba
diving in chocolate either way our
buster moon brought pretty special
moments to life we're gonna put the show
on whether crystal likes it or not but
first
we're gonna jump out that window
dream big dreams that's what i always
said right number seven is that a fierce
singing gray arctic wolf well sort of
it's also the voice of halsey shining
bright like a diamond paulie has the
most amazing number it is her first
major acting role but we wouldn't be
surprised if there were more after this
she's already very at home inside that
recording booth and guess what this girl
is on fire number eight who's that
impeccably dressed wolf introducing mr
crystal aka bobby cannavale the actor
has spent plenty of time in front of the
cameras and even in the recording booth
for the animated series big mouth but
joining the sing squad well this is
exactly the kind of big idea i'm talking
about number nine who else could play
this feisty pig so perfectly and i'm
very happy to be back doing sing since
the first sing movie crawl has been busy
with other projects
yeah
big time baby
including voicing multiple characters
including nick birch in big mouth with
his co-star bobby but busy as his
schedule is nothing was gonna stop him
from coming back it's a joy to voice him
while a lot of the other actors in sync
2 are experienced singers i like singing
although i'm not very good at it we'd
have to disagree there though we dig
gunter singing all the way i leave my
singing to the professional singing
which is probably the wrong way to do it
but it's how it's unfolded nah we think
winter said it best ah i think we pretty
much nailed it got the robot activating
piggy power
number 10 the gorilla with the voice of
a god if you could just give me some
dance lessons you would literally be
saving my life we've got taran eagerton
coming in hot as the fabulous johnny
come with me in rehearsal safety
eagerton has an impressive resume
including the movie musical rocket man
where we got a taste of the voice we'd
hear sounding just as sweet except
coming from an animated gorilla to
re-enter this world and revisit such a
lovely
um
character
you know is a dream come true working
with director garth jennings was a solid
part of what made the experience so
special you walk into one of those
recording sessions it begins with garth
explaining everything he's been up to
since the last time i was there and then
contextualizing whatever bit of the
story we're dealing with another vital
part of this all-star team number 11
has there ever been a more fabulous yak
i'm gonna win a ton of awards for this
we think not fingers crossed andre
brings comedy gold to sing too
unsurprising since he spends so much
time recording voices for animated
series like disenchantment and archer
he's new to the sing crew but he
definitely left his mark number twelve
last but certainly not least writer
director and actor in sing two the one
and only garth jennings i feel like he
loves to act out the characters for you
it's his movie and he can do what he
wants to and who wouldn't want to jump
at the chance to portray this fiery
iguana i love miss crawley jennings was
extremely busy on this project and the
first sing movie which happened to be
the very first time he directed a
live-action animated film but jumping
into the booth well it just made the
experience that much better she is sort
of ridiculous and delightful in equal
measure and just so much fun to play it
is such a joy to just stand behind a
microphone and try and be miss crawley
we just can't help but groove around in
our seats and tap our toes watching
along with the sing sequel with such an
all-star cast it's hard not to be
impressed we'll listen to these
performers any day which character was
your favorite